[Music]
hi I'm Jonathan Burke professor of
Finance at The Graduate School of
Business at Stanford University and I'm
Jules fan binsbergen a finance professor
at the Wharton School of the University
of
Pennsylvania and this is the all else
equal
podcast welcome back everybody today
we're going to talk about the different
between publicly traded firms and firms
that are held by private Equity
investors so privately held firms and in
particularly we would like to get a
better understanding of what the
tradeoffs are in being either publicly
traded or being privately held what are
the advantages and disadvantages of
being held by private Equity investors
versus being held by public investors in
the stock market yes Jules there are two
extremes the one extreme is you own your
own firm and you run your own firm and
in that case the firm is very well-run
you are monitoring and you do a very
good job but the problem is all of your
money is invested in one company and
that means you're not very Diversified
and you're taking on a lot of risk The
Other Extreme is a publicly run firm all
the investors in a public run firm Are
Diversified so that none of them are
taking on any idos and CTIC risks
they've all Diversified their risk away
so they're holding a much lower risk
position but because there's nobody who
has a stake in the firm or all their
money in The Firm there's not the same
incentive to Monitor and so the firm is
not well run so the basic tradeoff is
between diversification and effort
monitoring and the question is for which
firm does that tradeoff come out on
which side now obviously over time
financial markets have changed quite a
bit recently there is been a trend for a
type of fund a private Equity Fund that
still provides the benefits of
monitoring but at the same time allows
people to be Diversified these private
Equity Funds have two important groups
that interact with each other on the one
hand we have the so-called limited
partners who are Diversified investors
that provide money to the private Equity
Fund and on the other hand we have the
so-called General Partners these are the
partners that are involved in the
monitoring activity and the running of
the actual firms that the private Equity
Fund owns and they're generally less
Diversified than the limited partners so
Jews just to summarize basically it's a
way of trying to get our cake and eat it
investors in the private Equity Funds
are invested in many different private
Equity Funds and they may also have
stock market Investments so those
investors still have the benefits of
diversification but because the fund
takes companies private and they have
the benefit of private ownership
basically the general Partners they have
a skill at finding companies taking them
private fixing them monitoring the
companies and making sure those
companies are well run so it looks like
we can have our cake in yeah because if
you compare this to the historical
situation where a single individual held
one single firm we' clearly moved away
from that here because private Equity
Funds hold multiple private firms at the
same time and therefore we still get
this diversification but the question is
are we really saving our cake and eating
it in the sense that who is monitoring
the monitors exactly well first let's
admit that in the last 20 30 years
there's been a gigantic growth in these
fs and a concominant decrease in the
number of publicly traded companies
indeed so to some extent this has
certainly been an innovation but of
course it doesn't totally solve the
problem because as you point out
somebody has to monitor the monitor so
with the LPS are invested in many
private Equity Funds there's a limit to
how much they can monitor the general
part and then the general Partners have
to monitor their Investments and that
limits the number of Investments the
general Partners can invest it so while
the general partners are obviously much
more Diversified when the owner owned
only a single firm and All Is wealth in
the single firm it's still not as good
as a public Equity investor that is
investing in hundreds of firms so the
partnership would have a total
investment say 10 to 20 which is still
an improvement but it doesn't diversify
all way all the agreed these are all
good questions and we're very happy to
have an expert on the show that can help
us address some of them we are very
happy to have Eric zinterhofer with us
today Eric is a friend a graduate from
the University of Pennsylvania and a
very successful private Equity finer
he's a founding partner of search light
Capital partners and previously works
for Apollo Global Management Eric we're
very happy to have you on the podcast
welcome so much to our episode on the
tradeoff between between private and
public Equity markets so just to get the
conversation started let's start with
this important question which is that
over time the role of private equity and
value creation seems to have increased
and what do you think are the key
drivers of this trend there are really
several drivers that have led in essence
to private Equity taking share from the
public markets and if you think about
most private Equity firms they're not
big enough to buy companies that are
greater than a billion in market cap so
let's focus for a minute on public
companies that are less than a billion
in market cap and let's talk about the
conditions that exist if you're public
in that size Ranch it's not a great
place to be if you're a public company
first and foremost if you look at the
data public companies of less than a
billion in market cap trade at almost
four times less in multiple on a t to
Eva basis than larger cap companies and
in addition to that they're very El
liquid I was talking to a really close
friend of mine who was at one of the
biggest hedge funds who went to set up a
smaller fund but still a two billion
plus fund very well-respected great
active investor and I was talking to him
about this and I said would you ever buy
a stock in a company let's say your core
position is 20 million um he said yeah
it's probably about maybe a little bit
bigger I said would you ever buy a stock
in a company of less than a billion
market cap and he said absolutely not no
way and I started looking at the data
around this and what I saw is that the
average daily trading volume for kind of
this category of stocks less than a
billion is about $2.9 million a day and
if you do the math on that and say
you're buying at about 20% of average
daily trading volume it would take about
30 days to build a $20 million position
and also 30 days to take off a $20
million position so think about that
even if you're a more fundamental
long-term investor that's scary I mean
you're supposed to be investing in
liquid Securities you're supposed to be
able to move quickly in times of
dislocation you simply can't do that in
let's say a sub billion market cap
business the other factors we can go
through because there are many is the
fact that you have let's call it the
Vanguard Black Rock and state streets of
the world that are the primary owners of
public
companies and they're often something
like 25% of the votes in S&P 500
companies these are passive investors
who typically vote however they're told
to by The Advisory groups for different
shareholders and so shareholder
engagement can be all over the place as
a public
company and then I'll make one more
point and we can get into a lot of other
issues we took a company private last
year we saved almost $5 million in
public company costs on a business
that's doing about 70 million of IA
that's you know about 6% of ion was
saved just by being private now why is
that there's a lot of the red tape the
regulatory Dynamics the costs of being
public are enormous so Eric when I teach
Corporate Finance I talk about what I
call the fundamental tradeoff of
corporate finance and I tell them what
the trade-off of corporate finance is on
the one hand you can own your own
company so it's very well run but you're
highly undiversified on the other hand
you can sell the company we take the
company public so now you can hold a
diversified
portfolio but then there's nobody
looking over the shoulder management and
I call that the fundamental tradeoff of
corporate finance what do you think has
changed in the last few years that's
moved that tradeoff so that we move
towards private I'm biased around this
obviously but I feel very strongly that
public companies with board members that
are not major shareholders lack a
critical constituency to drive balanced
performance like any good functioning
machine you need different stakeholders
doing their best at
in any well functioning company and
active smart shareholders often
represented through the board are
critical to that the public company that
I'm most notably involved in is Charter
Communications where I'm lead
independent director and one of the huge
benefits of that company is that Liberty
John alone and the new house family are
significant shareholders very bright
active investors some of the best
capital allocators and strategists in
their field and it allows us to drive
great long-term decision making with
interested investors that have a real
stake in the game so you really view the
firm in that sense as a Nexus of
information of different stakeholders
that together lead to better decision-
making rather than a smaller group of
people driving all the decision making
is that's fair yeah I think it's fair I
think that ultimately if you don't have
a board that
really cares about driving long-term
stakeholder value and they care about
making whatever their average comp is
around $300,000 a year and they care
about being on the board and putting
that on their resume and using that for
other things then where is the fiduciary
function well then you say all right
well let's look at the shareholders in
these companies and it's index funds
primarily so there's no fiduciaries
there so where does that leave you it
leaves you with activist investors who
step into the fry who at times actually
have some pretty interesting ideas and
potentially beneficial but oftentimes
not so much and so there's a vacuum
there which if you're a talented
management team needs to be filled so
now let's talk about also the negative
bias toward being a public company at
less than a certain size and that is why
on Earth if you're the most most
talented management team in your
industry would you want to be the CEO of
a small public company you'd much rather
be in a private company with people who
are if you're confident in your
capabilities you're very confident to be
around smart people who can enhance what
you're doing and complement what you're
doing and by the way in a private
company context you're also willing to
put your money where your mouth is and
take shares instead of equity and
deliver on performance and get outsid
compensation around aligned performance
with those shareholders which in the
public company context is hard to do but
Eric I agree and that point you're
making a very good points but something
must have changed because we didn't have
this big private Equity Market 50 years
ago so I could think of two effects one
is the growth of
indexing and the other effect I could
think about is the growth of private
Equity companies one more which is the
growth of Regulation potentially I mean
the red tape in public markets I think
it's all of these things it's a
Confluence of events on the one hand for
all the reasons I cited it's becoming
more distasteful to be a public company
on the other hand private Equity I think
has evolved from the early days where it
was maybe more to simplified financially
Financial engineering focused and it's
evolved into really deep industry
knowledge with long-term value creation
plans because Financial Arbitrage has
totally disappeared and the industry has
shown an ability to evolve in that
direction and really focus on attracting
management and delivering value over a
longer period of time if you think about
those two things coming together it's
really just I think continues to
accelerate this trend that we're talking
about so Eric another thing that is
interesting is that different private
Equity companies have different
strategies in terms of how long they
would like to be in The Firm right so
suppose that it is indeed true which I
think it is as you said that certain
companies are just better run through
private ownership rather than public
ownership we're still seeing that
certain private Equity Funds take the
strategy that they take it private for a
while and then exit through public
markets but if it's really the value
creation from the private side that is
important why is that the way to exit
why isn't the way to get the value out
better to just get the cash flows out to
the investors and stay in it and there
is a group of private Equity investors
that indeed does Buy and Hold and gets
their money back through the cash flows
what do you think drives the difference
between these two models it's a great
question because ultimately if you're
taking a business public again that
you've taken private you would hope and
you would want that company to be more
successful the next time around as a
public company than it might have been
when you took it private previously so
what needs to have happened I think
there's really probably two key things
that need to have happened one is
perhaps through acquisition and perhaps
through growth is you've gained scale
you've gained adequate scale such that
maybe you've broken out of that small
cap realm and you've broken into a realm
where you have more liquidity and you
can attract good long-term shareholders
like my friend that I cited earlier that
can be smart long-term supporters of the
stock the second thing is you know in
many cases ideally you've brought in a
management team and you've put in board
practices that are aligned with building
long-term shareholder value so
compensation schemes incentive schemes
kpi schemes other things that are
designed around a set of value
initiatives that are not short-term in
nature but longer term in nature and I
think if you can do those two things and
reintroduce the company in the right way
then it's valid to come back back into
the public markets absent that I think
your point is correct that it wouldn't
be valid to do that maybe at that point
it'd be better to sell it to a strategic
that can generate synergies that can
integrate the business in a different
way into what they're doing if you look
at Dano which is a company they take
companies private and they keep them
private long-term Investments why are
they the exception or waren Buffett for
that examp why are they the exception
well I think there what great private
Equity firms aspire to be in terms of
their best practices and they're doing
it with permanent capital and they've
built cultures and practices that
attract great management teams focus on
the long term and build sustainable
long-term value I think that many of us
in the private Equity realm would love
to have the kind of capital base they
have because it allows you to stay with
companies even longer than you often can
in a private equity model in a private
Equity model you can stay with a company
for let's say 5 to eight years but as
you know from Dan and her and Buffett
when they build a great company they're
staying with it for 20 or 30 years and
once you find businesses like that you
want to stick with them for a long time
the disadvantage potentially of their
model and this is something that would
be interesting to study is what do they
do with the companies they should be
selling because part of at least the
Brookshire haway story is you're going
to be with us forever and I can't
imagine IM that their batting average is
a thousand so indeed there must be
companies for which going public would
have been better there too right and so
they must have made some mistakes there
and in terms of keeping them on for sure
so as the last topic a very tough topic
particularly in Academia is the question
of how do we do performance measurement
in private equity and just to give some
context whenever we have publicly traded
Securities although you already clearly
pointed out that not nearly all of them
are nearly as liquid as we often pretend
that they are but at least with publicly
traded companies we have performance
metrics and return metrics on a very
high frequency basis which allows us to
look at the value creation the value
evaluation of each of these companies
with good return data for private Equity
we don't really have valuations in a
market price which makes it very
difficult to compute returns and so how
for example can I hold a private Equity
company accountable against a benchmark
how do I do that without highfrequency
return data Jewels it's extremely
difficult and I will say our investors
struggle with this I can tell you all
the problems so that you can at least
know where those are I can posit
somewhat simplified solution which is
not perfect yep there are so many issues
in private Equity one is how at any
point in time these Investments are
being marked and all of this is audited
but it's still complicated there's less
volatility in private Equity because
you're using DCFS versus just comparing
to public marks which has advantages and
disadvantages some firms have been very
aggressive in using leverage not only at
the portfolio level but at the fund
level and that can skew a lot of
different things that can be used to
generate higher IRS which some investors
really care about and that has been used
by certain firms very aggressively in
the last 10 years particularly in a
lower interest rate environment where
the cost of that leverage was less I
think in this interest rate environment
those strategies won't work as well so
there's a ton of noise in the numbers
quarter to quarter ultimately the metric
that is the only objective metric at the
end of the day is looking at a mostly
realized fund and just looking at the
multiple uninvested Capital that they've
generated simply how much Capital they
call and how much did they return and
you can look at that Company by company
and ultimately across the portfolio and
you can time scale it because you know
when those Investments were made and
when they were sold and everything else
IRS marks in between there's a ton of
noise in the data a ton of noise in the
data what we focus our investors on is
multiple uninvested capital and entrum
step is something called DPI in the
industry which is what you've realized
along the way so that's distributed
Capital at any point in time versus how
much paid in capital or Capital called
you have delivered and again those are
objective metrics around what a company
is worth that you bought and sold it for
so it's very hard if you start looking
at it over a long time frame once these
funds are realized that's where you can
get much better data and for funds that
have been around a long time you can
Benchmark them versus the public markets
during those same time scales but if
you're looking at the most recent funds
in any of these Firs
is particularly Investments that were
made very aggressively in the last few
years in high valuation environments I
can assure you a lot of those marks are
coming down from where they're being
marked and if you had to put a number on
the delay that we generally see with
these markdowns compared to public
markets already moving is this within a
few months is it six months is it a year
what is your estimate it can take I
think we're in a little bit unchartered
territory this Jules this is a hard
question for me to answer just because
we've talked a little bit about our firm
and our strategy but we've invested on
average at seven and a half times even
uh over our last year funds which is
quite low compared to the rest of the
market and so we're able to mark more
conservatively and we don't really face
these issues but if you've been paying
15 and 20 times revenue for businesses
over the last few years which a lot of
private Equity firms have paid the
question is you know how do you justify
that now it can't and yet these marks
haven't come down yet so what they're
saying is two things really they're
saying look we've grown earnings enough
and somehow the multiple hasn't come
down enough to offset that growth and
earnings but I don't understand how
that's the case I mean your discounted
rate has got to have gone up at least by
5% over the last year or two that's a
massive number you guys can do the math
on a tenure that's going to decrease the
aggregate value of the asset before debt
by like 30% or 40% over a 10-year DCF so
I don't really understand how earnings
growth can really offset that in a
one-year period not to mention you have
to you still have to look at public
comps I mean that should be part of your
valuation and those have come down
dramatically as well so I think it's
something that I think could be a
problem for the industry when people
look back in a couple of years were
these valuations really accurately done
or not if you are a private Equity
investor in terms of the time commitment
it takes for you to be involved with the
firms that you're invested in what is
the equivalent time commitment that
we're talking about right because
obviously we have activist investors as
you said and we have people at Vanguard
or others that go to a shareholder
meeting and once in a while vote here
and there that is not even close to the
type of time commitment that you make
right yeah I would say I'm on a public
company board where we're not a
shareholder at Search Le and then I'm
involved in companies that were major
shareholders on where I'm on the board
maybe other partners alongside of me at
this point I'm spending 10x the time on
the companies we own versus let's say
just being a public company board member
and the level of detail I know is just
massive compared to that it's a
completely different Dynamic and I've
got a whole team of people that are
equally focused on it I think that the
industry as a whole will continue to be
fine but I definitely feel like
investors are going to have to shift
back to more I'd say fundamentals in
their approach and it's just going to
take a little bit longer the good thing
about the public markets is people
adjust more quickly to that if I talk to
my hedge fund friends their Frameworks
are moving back to ones that maybe were
more familiar in like the mid
2000s coming out of the Doom bubble
bursting that 2005 time frame type of
thing or maybe 20112 but in the private
Equity realm it'll take longer for
investors to realize wait a minute
what's really going on here this is
unprecedented right we've been in a zero
rate environment for 10 12 years and you
have a whole generation of investors
who've gotten into some really bad
habits really bad habits and I have to
continually remind people who are in
their mid-30s what the do com bubble
looked like and what that meant when it
burst I mean we have relatively senior
investors who didn't they weren't
investing during that period they were
young kids so history Rhymes obviously
there's differences in this cycle which
a lot of right people will talk about we
have strong views on but a lot of people
don't have that historical context and
investors themselves in private Equity
Funds often don't have that historical
contact so this is going to be a big
learning experience for people over the
next few years we have the technology so
we can monitor and set
incentives so people will behave in a
way that we can predict will be good for
us as
investors and that to me is the reason
why we have the growth of prividence
just the whole idea that previously if I
give you money then the only way to
discipline you is I have to be able to
take my money out at any time right yeah
and the ability to give somebody money
for 10 years and not ask for your money
back that comes with a technology where
I can monitor and I can check what's
going on so that I can affect this
enormous value added because of course
if I know you're going to do good then I
want to give you the money and then that
allows you to do a lot of good I think
that's interesting that's a good thread
the other thread that I would pull on
and and you say trust I would say
alignment alignment you're right that's
the right word no alignment is
everything it goes back to the symbiotic
relationship that I described earlier in
this talking about boards and everything
if you have alignment between all the
stakeholders over a long period of time
it's the biggest substitute for a lack
of judgment around whether you can
totally trust somebody or not obviously
you want to invest with people with high
integrity we all try to assess that our
investors assess it with us they do
massive background checks we do the same
thing on our CEOs we put them through
all these different personality tests we
meet with people multiple times to get
to know them in different settings we do
that when we interview people ultimately
though what's your backup plan it's
alignment and this is where the Achilles
heel in private Equity because it's
grown so much is lack of alignment so
where does alignment exist it exists in
the smaller firms where most of the
money like I a firm like search light
the management fees that we earn every
year really go to pay the team we don't
really make excess money on management
fees where we make all our money is on
carry and on the amount we invest in the
fund which is substantial and so
investors are like all right you're
using the management fees to hire a team
you guys as the owners of the business
aren't really taking home a big salary
every year and you've put a ton of money
in the fund alongside of us the GP so us
search like collectively are like the
second largest investor in the fund and
then we're going to make most of our
money on profits and we have to get
above 8% return everything else so
people are like okay these guys are
aligned with us and that counts for a
huge amount now when you get to be a
massive public company one of my
Founders came from KKR I came from
Apollo things change right those
management
fees actually drive huge profitability
and those are recurring and they're
known more or less each year and so the
public markets love those fees they put
a higher multiple on those fees do on
carry which is it's hard to predict it's
a big one year is small the next that
type of cash flow doesn't behave well
for public investors so what happens
your motivation changes once you're
public your job then is to grow AUM and
that's and then all of a sudden maybe
you're not aligned anymore and I look
for alignment everywhere and this is
again most public companies lack
alignment for all the reasons we talked
about earlier so that's part of the
issue there Eric thank you so much for a
really interesting discussion yes indeed
Eric thanks so much it's my pleasure and
it's nice to meet you I have to say it
might be a bit of a Day of Reckoning
coming in private equ thanks for
listening to the all else equal podcast
please leave us a review at Apple
podcast we'd love to hear from our
listeners and be sure to catch our Next
Episode by subscribing or following our
show wherever you listen to your podcast
for more information and episodes visit
all else equalp podcast.com or follow us
on LinkedIn the alll SQL podcast is a
production of Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business and is
produced by University
[Music]
FM